e deu play meu Deus que emoção tá que é
que eu faço beleza eu faço aqui agora e
aí galera que assiste meu canal tudo bom
com vocês eu só você acaba mesmo com
saudade dos vídeos blogs aqui de frente
faz no blog clique em gostei e agora eu
tô falando mais grosso aí que eu vou ser
papai é
o pai de menino um princípio primeiro
não ficar desse tamanho depois ele fica
desse tamanho depois deve tomar banho
depois que andar de moto causa
preocupação que me pega de madrugada
será que meu filho vai empinar pneu de
moto aí a gente quer apoiar sonho filho
não pode interromper já tive pensando
vai ter cachorro meu Deus nessas ruas
que ele vai ensinar poder botar a mão no
chão para dar lugar ao cachorro em volta
dele que esses prints gosta de dedo
primeira coisa que eu vou fazer
registrar criança no tempo certo que eu
não sei o que é que de 1990 para trás
todo mundo é registrado algo de errado a
pessoa faça o meu pai mesmo para você
tem uma 54 anos mas na verdade é 56 era
uma raiva desses cartório tinha que te
botar nas datas tudo errado das pessoas
tem gente que quer me botar medo às
vezes ela rehioes agora tipo as crianças
chorando que incomoda as pessoas agora
vai ser a tua casa tu vai ter o olhar
das pessoas te julgando porque teu filho
isso me preocupa que meu filho vai
chorar sim no avião né Aí quem tiver
reclamando perto eu vou olhar e vou
falar gente mas o avião é dele e o nó
ver qual vai ser as pessoas ficaram me
pressionando não vai ser Gerais ou não
vai me dizer que não vai enferrujar de
novo quando vai ser porque seu nome do
meu filho foi gerbert a Maria vai ser a
mãe do Jerry e a mãe do diário e fala
assim tchau verde não vai comer seu
cuscuz com formigas eu vou sonhar Apesar
dele não deixa uma criança criança
cresce né achei galera 26 anos aí para
ela ficar pronta gostoso fez com a minha
vida transforma numa só para saber para
quem não gosta de ti lá na escola me
chama de Marlon e sai acelerando uma
Lamborghini dele e eu porque eu sou o
quê
e a gente criou o menino para o mundo e
foi um pouco difícil escolheu não porque
já tá escolhendo não de menino e menina
né porque poderia ser qualquer um que o
fio que está no BBB né se não seria
menininha aí passa vários nomes na
cabeça ela Stephanie ela não Stephanie
não de espécimes nome de menina tentadas
a folha nome de menina que você percebe
a senhora já tá em último lugar e no pé
de goiaba e eu sempre muito preocupado
de telefone de anos deve dormir com a
Maria tá vendo te amar e te pego lá em
cima tu tá enrolada ela não gosta
Stephanie ele daquelas duas goleadas do
campo aí para mim advém isso aí não lá
na pontinha cai não consegue vai isso e
isso não funciona mais só girar que ela
destaca rápido que atua muito Stephanie
desce daí certo Olha Maria a criança meu
Deus do céu velho e assim Horizonte da
cuca não sabe falar direito de alongar
eu falando fera que subiu essas coisas
que Stephanie é danada Esther Esther
quando fala step corre criança corta com
aquelas calcinha de babado aqui um dia
balançando ela gordinha pesada que você
pensa assim tem um tolete ali então não
Flora
é legal flora flor best Flow abelhas
ajuda a podem numerização do planeta é
não tá querendo também não vai ser uma
abelha é só mexer não falou Flora Flora
gosta de passarinho beija-flor entendeu
de melancia Comer melancia os que a
semente ligado a ver até um churrasco a
melancia de menina a gente pensa em
vários também é óbvio que eu queria
botar o nome muito melhor do que o meu
porque eu sei o que é não sabia escrever
o nome até a oitava série meus pai
queria dar ideia também mas eu achei
melhor não porque eu acho que não tem
respaldo uma pessoa que vive no mundo
contanto Lucas entretanto Mateus aí bota
o nome do vídeo o Whindersson aí no
faculta muito bem muito tanto Gabriel
vai lá no Wilson Eu acho que um casal
desse tem que aprender até carteira de
motorista dele com aquele que dirige uma
pessoa que não sabe o aluno filho vai
fazer mexer mostrando rapaz Pensa aí
também botar o nome tipo era o pessoal
gringo né de bota o nome de qualquer
coisa Michael Jackson botou o nome do
filho cobertor Branca Ah mas é só lá que
eu vou e boto o nome desse jeito é tão
fica
a brincadeira torta pode menina voltava
espátula ou tão bonito espátula tem a
ver com um passar as coisas né formar
espátula entendeu você bota no Google
significado de instrumento do pedreiro
construção crescer é difícil é você dá o
nome uma pessoa que você não sabe que
ela vai ser isso você sabe o que a
pessoa faz é muito melhor sábado eu fui
jogador a dia e pronto zagueirão do
carai Adilson ex-jogador de Para de
jogar para por 55 anos Alguém vende
rendimentos PC Adalberto também mas
Adalberto no dado que Adalberto é nome
de gente vai entrar nas costas ao porosa
primeira palavra daqui a fazer outro dia
três e foi então que a gente escolheu
João Miguel é só significado de pote
João bote Miguel bote João Miguel vai
dar iluminação Divina sou de energia de
Deus por cima eles de Deus tomara que
pareça Maria seja lindo porque se fosse
para ser feito Tipo tinha feito tem
vontade de ter outro Nossa tenho muita
vontade de ter uma menina mas eu tenho
medo também de ter dois filhos porque
pode rolar dá não
o medo que tem escada assistir novela
mexicana rapaz ele não pegar para quem
vai ficar com a herança de papai muito
muito para isso que eu quero Educar para
ficar com essas cabeça mas não perder
pra esse lado que eu sou babão Eu sei
que eu sou babá hoje eu tenho triste
queriam e me fala aí eu vou sair lá no
Piauí ganhar dinheiro ganhar a vida o
meu filho tem um helicóptero Rapaz então
vou ter que trocar direto vai estudar na
escola particular vai encapar o mesmo
com papel de presente que é para passar
aqui ó você vai para a Disney vai mas
vai na lagarta maconheiros lá em Santa
Lúcia também não importa que amigo do
filho de existe uma Ele Chama ele para
conhecer a lagarta EA preocupação não
passa viu meu amigo que eu tô olhando
para essa mesinha aqui tô só preciso da
altura de uma festa aqui só vai dar para
o Enem agora você não vai postar
desculpa de que o seu pai né Para ser
mais antissocial do que eu sou porque o
Deus tá ligado ninguém me ver no lugar
nenhum posso não eu vou ter que ir para
casa o João Miguel Carbon na parede sabe
como é né irmão sair de casa a gente só
se alguém é que faz em casa mas ninguém
sai de cabelo feio só vá
há dez anos de idade domingo assistindo
desenho ainda porque esses três
porquinhos Tão junto aí eu morava lá no
Senhor juntar agora e esse é o perigo
não pensa ligado e o Lobo Mau chegando e
eu falando aí ó aí é onde mora o perigo
que o carro vai chegar lá no bar mas só
para na casa do senhor pudim e não tem
voltei não vai nascer e o mundo tá
pegando fogo né meu irmão médico disse
que dá para escolher o dia do parto eu
pensava que era tipo assim tipo quando
tiver perto do dia você tem que ficar
olhando assim começa tanto tempo que uma
hora vai ter Ai bora aí o médico você
pode escolher o dia do parto aí eu falei
para ele que eu queria que nascesse
depois da academia ele falou olha hoje
não dá para segurar até 2025 Aí eu ah
então tá bom então vamos lá em outubro
mesmo Como é que eu faço o gás para
crianças porque se eu for educado do
jeito que eu aprendi eu vou ser preso
faz entende a temática é porque eu tenho
tempo hoje eu organizei tudo para poder
ter tempo para poder criar o meu filho
bem bonitinho e educar ele meu pai tinha
tempo meu pai tinha 45 minutos em casa
até ele chegava e falava ó ele fez esse
esse esse esse ele fazer os cálculos
treinar tá de boa entendi OK tudo é
pensa
tô entendendo entendeu porque eu já fico
imaginando dizendo Maria o menino vai
derrubar o Cabeludo no sofá Maria Mas
por que que eu apanhava seu derrubasse o
valor do sofá porque era o único só para
15 anos de história então um pouco em
amo claro eles você pode botar outro
sofá amanhã mas aí vai ser um babaquinha
onde o meu pai me deu Playstation 12 mas
eu estava dormindo mesmo era do Xbox
Matrix and Little Experience ampliado
Santiago por isso que tem uma técnica
para educar ele tá eu vou fingir até os
18 anos dele quem tem nada que pedir
ajuda de vocês eu vou montar todo
entendeu Vou levar então Rodrigo Faro
Vamos fazer ele chorar vamos dar uma
moto aí para trabalhar vou chegar na
kitnet dele para agora eu vou morar aqui
na mesma da mesma casa entendeu ele só
fingir eu mato Chrome Liga para ele
chorando para aperriar mesmo eu fico lá
de outro tá querendo tomar meu Uno Fire
aí ele faz 18 anos é eu faço a festa
andar bate-papo tão grande que ele tava
brincando mas ele já vem né vai me odiar
uns 12 anos mas depois né vai ficar
tranquilo
e eu espero que você tenha gostado em
ter ficado feliz por mim porque eu tô
explodindo de felicidade eu queria que
você comentasse aqui em baixo qual é o
mundo que você queria para o seu filho
ou filha quando ele nascesse que o meu
Renascer no fundo não esquece de
assistir com os irmãos cabelo que é uma
série ridícula derrota besteirol que eu
postei no meu canal tem um episódio né E
lembre-se que sozinho inteligentes acham
graça de qualquer coisa que você
assistir 17 minutos alguma coisa não
acha graça de nada você tá vivendo
errado você tem que entender quando a
coisa não tem sentido nenhum que é para
massagear seu cérebro te fazer esquecer
de qualquer coisa que está acontecendo
ao Senado ó e apenas um polir uma
besteira tamo junto é nós pegar por
esperar tanto tempo por vídeo um beijo
aqui para Maria te amo demais Maria
obrigado por esse presente maravilhoso
que você aparecer na minha vida um beijo
para os meus outros parabéns para os
meus pais vovós e um beijo João Miguel
que eu amo demais esse é o primeiro
vídeo que eu faço sobre você Meu filho
espero que você goste quando você
assistir esse filme não tenho vergonha
de mim eu já vai nascer
eu tava nem me Ok mas já está ele já
entra no chato cara dava para onde hein
está tudo ok Down [ __ ] entraram já que
vai ver vai voltar beijo olha mais olha
mágica um dois três e eu sabia que meu
irmão mas a gente com essas coisas Volta
hora sua vez procurou seu cordão em 1
e o irmão cabelo agora qual será o final
dessa história O que é será que
acontecerá com os irmãos Capela Qual
será o final deste enredo nesta Trama
desde o que você quiser chamar escreva
nos comentários o que você quer que
aconteça que nós iremos fazer acontecer
e quer dizer só se nós gostarmos Rosa
irmãos cabelo hein continua
E aí